prendre son destin en main
je me suis souvent demandé ce que cette
expression voulait dire prendre son
destin en main en revanche l'expression
on n'échappe pas à son destin
celle-ci gelé comprise très vite son
destin mon père n'y a pas échappé et il
a dessiné le mien je suis la fille d'un
homme mort
nous sommes le 30 juillet 1971 j'ai neuf
mois mon père embarque dans un avion
militaire avec ses élèves officiers de
saint cyr pour un entraînement en soit
en parachute à son bord 37 personnes
ils n'ont jamais pu sauter l'avion s'est
écrasé il n'y a eu aucun survivant
mon père avait 31 ans pour expliquer la
mort et un enfant françoise dolto disait
on meurt quand on a fini de vivre mon
père lui est mort avant qu'il finisse
vraiment de vivre à leur petite fille
je ne comprenais pas et puis quand on
est enfant la mort est réversible
c'est comme quand on joue au cow boys et
aux indiens on meurt et on se relève
on meurt et puis on revit alors bien sûr
on j'étais vivante mais anéanti perdu
j'ai ressenti la mort sa mort comme une
absence prolongée
puis comme si une séparation et puis
plus tard comme un abandon puisque
puisque je ne l'avais pas connu je ne
voulais pas être triste du moins c'est
ce que me disait ma famille et c'est
autour de moi parce que pour eux perdre
quelqu'un que l'on ne connaît pas
c'était pas aussi grave que si on perd
quelqu'un qu'on connaît
je n'étais pas vraiment la fille de mon
père puisque mon père est mort avant que
je le connaisse j'avais neuf mois et à 9
mois on ne se souvient de rien alors je
l'appelais par son
raymond michel jamais papa et pourtant
quand j'étais enfant j'avais un rêve un
rêve qui revenait sans cesse dans ce
rêve je suis au milieu d'une rangée de
militaires presque infinies je ne vois
pas les visages
je m'avance vers eux et je le cherche
ce père dont le visage m'échappe mais à
chaque visage que je tourne je ne trouve
pas c'est pas lui
je ne peux pas le trouver parce que
chaque personnage a son visage gommer
comme dans un dessin où il n'aurait pas
fini d'être dessinée alors dans mon rêve
je crie je hurle je suis paniqué je
n'arrive pas à respirer
c'est pire je n'arrive pas à le voir ni
dans mon souvenir le plus ancien ni même
dans mon imaginaire tout le long de mon
enfance de mon adolescence j'ai pleuré
beaucoup pleuré mais quand on est une
fille de militaire on doit pas montrer
ses émotions on doit rester dîner quand
on me disait d'arrêter d'être triste je
comprenais je ne peux pas être triste
nous on l'a connu c'est normal mais toi
non on m'avait imposer une façon de
vivre son absence est une façon de faire
le deuil
un deuil qui serait supportable
celui de ne pas le faire un deuil dans
lequel on ne va pas sur une tombe
l'armée est aussi ma famille m'avait
demandé de me taire de ne pas poser de
questions que s'était il passé ce jour
là
pourquoi un accident d'avion en temps de
paix arrive
que s'était-il passé je ne le savais pas
on en a jamais vraiment parlé alors vers
15 ans je me retrouve dans les
bibliothèques de beaubourg pour essayer
d'aller chercher des indices
des articles de presse des bouts
d'histoires de son histoire de mon
histoire
j'ai jamais rien trouvé au compris
c'était absurde de vouloir connaître les
détails de l'accident
c'était sordide et autant ne plus en
parler absurde de vouloir aller à la
recherche de la vérité qui était
horrible un carnage humain tous brûlés
vifs
c'était morbide d'être autant accaparé
par sa mort pas normal de pleurer à
chaque fois que je voyais un homme en
treillis
c'était le passé et il fallait que
j'oublie
on m'avait imposer une façon de faire de
deuil j'ai voulu essayer de le faire
autrement d'abord sa tombe
je ne savais pas où était la tombe de
mon père on ne m'avait pas donné le
droit d'y aller pourtant elle doit bien
exister cette tombe à 35 ans je suis
allé la chercher
c'était dans un petit cimetière pas très
loin de pau là où l'accident d'avion
avait eu lieu la tombe de mon père était
là avec pour unique plaque inscrits
capitaine michel rémy morts en service
commandé le 30 juillet 1971 alors je
fais faire une autre plaque où je fais
inscrire michel rémy maris pères et
grands pères parce que c'était aussi un
mari un père et un grand père alors je
commence à m'occuper de lui je lave sa
tombe
je mets des fleurs je lui parle je
pleure se crée alors une relation père
fille différente de celle qui m'a été
imposée
six mois plus tard
je redécouvre en fouillant dans les
affaires familiales
le paris match de juillet 1971
l'accident d'avion militaire de pau en
avait fait la une
un accident en temps de paix ça a été un
drame national
quand mon père est mort il n'était pas
seul il était avec 36 autres militaires
ces élèves officiers de saint cyr le
pilote le copilote et d'autres officiers
tous mariés avec femme et enfants dans
ce paris match je redécouvre les photos
du crash d'avion et puis aussi les
photos des victimes
des petites photos d'identité en noir et
blanc de chacun de ces hommes là en
double page il était écrit leur nom et
puis en plus petits étaient inscrits le
nombre d'enfants qu'ils avaient eu au
total une cinquantaine d'enfants
je ne sais pas ce qui m'anime
et pourquoi je décide de faire ce que je
vais faire mais je savais qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose pour nous pour les
enfants je décide de faire le contraire
de ce que tout le monde me dit de faire
je veux vivre
l'enterrement de mon père
me vient alors une idée un peu étrange
l'idée d'organiser une commémoration
pour nous pour les enfants à l'endroit
même où l'accident d'avion avait eu lieu
à pau à l'école des troupes aéroportées
mais d'abord il faut que je les retrouve
ses enfants qui étaient devenus adultes
35 ans plus tard alors je pars à leur
recherche
les retrouver n'a pas été simple
d'abord parce que l'armée ne m'avait pas
accordé le droit de passer directement
par e la grande muette n'avait imposé de
passer par les maires les veuves qui
avait vécu un cauchemar et qui avait
préféré se taire pour s'en sortir
certaines ont accepté d'autres ont
refusé que je contacter leurs enfants
chaque rencontre est une souffrance
terrible
chaque discussion chaque coup de
téléphone avec ces familles
c'est presque insurmontable de douleurs
de chagrin je mets en tout deux ans
allait retrouver ses enfants
et nous sommes presque tous là ce 12
octobre 2007
il faisait beau le ciel était bleu ce
bleu du sud si foncé des arbres étaient
doré il y avait un silence particulier
comme une forme de respect le même avion
que celui de l'accident un arrêt de
classe était habillée d'un parachute
grand ouvert sur une de ses ailes
un prêtre militaires étaient là avec les
officiels les militaires du camp le
général de l'etap le général de la
promotion
on nous étions réunis pour l'enterrement
nous allions célébrer une messe pour eux
en présence des enfants
la commémoration allait commencer j'ai
pris la parole j'ai parlé de l'absence
de mon père par laquelle j'avais créé sa
présence j'ai parlé de lui et combien
j'étais fier d'être sa fille et combien
il me manquait j'ai parlé aussi des
autres hommes morts avec lui ce jour là
et puis après la messe il ya eu l'appel
aux morts
un rituel militaire pour ce genre de
commémoration j'avais proposé à l'armée
que pendant l'appel aux morts chaque
enfant puisse répondre à l'appel du nom
de son père par la phrase morts en
service commandé à chacun des pères
appelé chaque enfant a répondu mort en
service commandé
la liste semble est si longue
quand est arrivé le nom de mon père
capitaine michel rémy j'ai pu répondre
morts en service commandé
quand j'ai prononcé cette phrase devant
tous ces militaires qui se tenait devant
moi je me suis souvenu du rêve de mon
enfance de cette rangée de militaires
presque infini au visage gommer le temps
s'est suspendu il ya eu un silence
intense et je l' ai vu mon père est
apparu comme dans mon rêve
il est sorti de s'arranger il s'est
retourné il m'a regardé il m'a souri
il a même ri elle avait les yeux bleus
aussi bleu la même couleur que les yeux
de mon fils max il avait l'air serein et
puis il est reparti ce visage gommer du
rêve de mon enfance c'était enfin
dessiner devant mes yeux c'était pas
juste un visage il était là il était
venu me voir moi sa fille
cette histoire ce rêve d'enfance m'a
construite m'a aidé à être qui je suis
aujourd'hui ce que j'ai appris c'est
qu'on peut faire autrement que ce qu'on
nous impose
bien sûr on ne peut pas changer
l'histoire
mais on peut se libérer même des choses
les plus tenaces dramatique
on a tous des choses lourdes dont on a
besoin de se libérer pour avancer pour
vivre on a tous la possibilité de
poursuivre d'évoluer dans son histoire
aussi compliqué ou dramatique soit elle
pour ne pas y rester bloqué coincés à
l'intérieur comme dans un mauvais rêve
dont on n'a pas le contrôle qui nous
échappe où on se réveille trop tôt et
surtout ce que j'ai appris c'est que si
un rêve n'est pas terminée et qui nous
hante nous habite avec insistance c'est
peut-être que nous avons quelque chose à
faire avancer changer les choses
peut-être être dans le mouvement
sûrement si un rêve n'est pas achevé on
peut le finir même si on ne sait pas où
cela peut nous mener
merci